mayroy ce qui m'exaspère en ce moment ça
fait trois semaines qu'il ya un conflit
et que depuis trois semaines il ya une
personne qui reste complètement muette
c'est monsieur macron quand même là
lafargue m'explique on en a parlé d'un
des leurs pour ça parce qu'il va falloir
parler mais moi je suis prête à aller
beaucoup plus loin parce que ce ce
personnage déjà je trouve que il a plus
sa place au jour d'aujourd'hui
ouais d'autre part d'autre part par
contre ils sont dans un gouvernement où
à mon sens et je n'engage que ma parole
à mon sens ils sont déconnectés de
certaines réalités
donc je lance une invitation et je me
lance à vous puisque vous êtes en face
de moi mais si vous voulez pas venir
vous inviterez vos collègues ya aucun
problème
j'aimerais bien prendre quelqu'un un
stage à la maison non décisive mais si
vraiment pas ce que j'aime en mai un
stage quelqu'un en stage donc se rendre
compte de ce que nous vivons au jour le
jour à la maison j'ai à faire avec on
l'espère un observateur
on les voit là avec son budget jeu et
vous savez je suis écouté mois écouter
les chants je suis les six mois terminés
s'il vous plaît allez je suis assistante
de vie je suis spécialisée alzheimer
je travaille à domicile en cesu alors
monsieur macron l'a dernièrement il nous
a fait toute une sérénade en le disant
les employeurs de cesu vous allez
pouvoir payer un peu plus vos employés
pour leur donner du pouvoir d'achat
vous savez combien j'ai gagné de l'heure
en plus des parce que c'est honteux
quand même c'est 0 17 centimes de
l'heure d'accord le plein d'essence ils
augmentaient de combien s'il vous plaît
alors là ça me révolte parce que je fais
un plein d'essence par semaine attendez
j'ai pas terminée parce que monsieur
macron parle cette semaine par le biais
de son premier ministre parce qu'il n'a
pas le courage de venir en parler lui
même donc j'aimerais bien qu'il
m'appelle comme ça je vais lui expliquer
de vive voix
parce que c'est terrible de pas pouvoir
parler aux gens le fassent et donc là il
nous dit on va vous mettre une prime
d'essence expliquez-moi comment une
assistante de vie peut justifier du
nombre de kilomètres
quand je prends une mamie qui à 81 18
ans que je l'amène jusqu'à cannes parce
que j'habite fréjus et que je fais 45 km
les 45 km retour qu'est ce qui va me
donner cette prime d'essence parce que
c'est incalculable d'accord d'autre part
monsieur macro il ya à peu près un mois
ou deux dit alors vous êtes le
travailleur moyen vous avez entre 40 et
50 ans alors je vais vous expliquer un
truc ça c'est tout à fait personnelle et
je parle encore que en mon nom je suis
en instance de divorce depuis quatre ans
j'ai un ex mariés qui se désiste de tout
règlement bancaire d'accord bon ça c'est
une ce monsieur macro me dis ok vous
allez pouvoir faire un crédit pour
apaiser vos charges et faire un
allongement de vos échéances trois ans
que j'ai été voir trois banques
vous savez quoi les trois banques vous
savez ce qui m'a répondu mais non on
sait pas combien on va pouvoir vous
saisir si jamais vous divorcez donc vous
savez quoi vos familles l'euro on peut
pas vous les donner nan nan mais moi ce
que c'est très grave
oui je ferme et 300 euros de plus
monsieur hanouna je gagne 2000 euros par
mois
cyril pardon je t'explique je m'excuse
je suis derrière le plus sûr il se gagne
2000 euros par mois chez 1100 euros de
mensualité ces banques ne sont pas
capables de laisser dire un co
emprunteur parce que la justice depuis
quatre ans ne fait pas son travail dans
une histoire de divorce et je me
retrouve face à des banquiers refusent
un crédit de 20 mille euros pour que je
puisse vivre décemment avec ma fille de
13 ans bien sûr c'est inacceptable et là
pendant tout ce temps là on vous demande
mais pourquoi vous êtes en colère mais
ça c'est mon cas pas si vous avez 50
millions et donc je veux quelqu'un en
stage à la maison j'ai une bonne
gratuitement vis ma vie
voilà on est bien d'accord vient habiter
chez moi et tu va réaliser parce que je
pense que ces gens là doivent sortir un
petit peu de leur univers
alors on arrive
[Applaudissements]